earlier in the show I mentioned when I
went through the brackets with my
daughter it's her first time she's ever
gone through brackets she just chose
numbers and and letters and and for
instance she took Clemson a couple of
rounds cuz she liked the pawl but all of
a sudden she starts focusing on Duke
which for a Michigan guy was crushing me
so I had no idea why she kept saying
Duke until I finally turned her I said
why and she says because of secret life
of pets so I tweeted that out today
saying thank you Eric Stonestreet pretty
great now I'm a and now I have the
opportunity to thank him in person you
there Eric Eric Stonestreet you there on
your bridge how are you Eric good man I
couldn't be in a more peaceful serene
place right now I'm I'm in Napa and it's
raining and I'm in the woods
man I feel like one with myself finally
hmm and so I hate to pierce that bubble
if you will by saying as a Michigan man
the fact that my daughter's chosen Duke
because of your portrayal of this this
beautiful animal it cuts deep Eric it
cuts deep yeah but I mean you know it
could have been Ohio State yeah I could
have been Buckeye or any lion you don't
want any of Adaline at least Duke is
it's just threatening to all of us
across the it'd be like it'd be like you
know I had a daughter and there was a
Jayhawk character and she picked Jayhawk
you know I would hurt far worse far
worse for me so Duke is still is still
even for Kansas State even in Manhattan
Kansas you have a problem with Duke I
don't have a problem with Duke no I mean
we're just I'm jealous of Duke I'm like
I am with any great institution that
keeps winning and winning championships
and it has great basketball history but
you know kids the state has great
basketball history people forget that
but we do have great basketball history
but you know the rivalry between Kay you
and k-state is one of you know it's it's
envy like Lawrence Kansas is nothing
special it's not
people are going to Lawrence Kansas to
play basketball they're going there
because of the institution in the end
the history of the program do you feel
we can achieve that in Manhattan Kansas
at some point well you'll be happy to
know because my daughter also likes cats
on occasion she chose Kansas State to
advance past Creighton in the first
round yes I don't even know what the
crate
what is crate and Creighton what well
what are they are they the Bulldogs
that'll be a perfect the Blue Jays yeah
she's not into birds as much
cratenbarrel yeah at cratenbarrel very
good Mike Chris very very good
cratenbarrel
hilarious well make tell your daughter
that make no mistake cat birds very good
hey I would I would be remiss if I did
not let you have a little bit of the
floor here on on Jordy Nelson getting
cut at big time Kansas State football
player I believe that he still has all
the records and then the Chiefs what do
you think they're up to
Eric well you know I don't think the
Chiefs will make a play on play on Jordy
I would love Jordy to come to Kansas
City obviously we would be lucky to have
him but I also want what's best for
Jordy you accept going to the Raiders I
can't believe he would go to the razors
I don't want Jordy Nelson go under the
Raiders he's not a Raiders guy I would
rather him go to the Patriots than the
Raiders that's the team's that's the
first rate that's the first one that
he's visiting he's also seeing Seattle
and Saints in the Saints which one would
you be happy for him well I'd be happy
for him I'd be happy for him with
trooper what's your breeze - I'd be I'd
be happy for him if he wants the
Patriots
he would be great there that the town
would love him he's like he's he's a
good dude and be happy for him a free
agency with the Chiefs you know it's
been interesting you know now we've got
two deep threats at wideout which is you
know obviously gonna help with our
taking a man out of the box I mean you
got a cover both Tyreke Hill and what's
the same from the Rams we just got Sammy
Watkins yeah Sammy Watkins a me Watkins
you got to cover those guys deep so you
know good luck with that
which is gonna help our run game which
is a cream hunt we got you know
offensive linemen we just locked loss
tax Alton but I feel like we got the
pieces in place there we can
that in will probably draft a guard I
think our first draft choice that 50
whatever 456 I'm like that I would
imagine it's going to be an edge rusher
would be my guess okay all right we need
a little we need a little help there but
you know we got Mitchell Schwartz at
right tech I'm a you know I'm a no line
guy you know I love the OL line right
hmm I know please no you boy you
understand right tackle we got a great
left tackle we got an amazing Center
Mitch Morris will be back from injury
next year Jordan Devi at guard we got
Brian Whitman at guard hammering you
know for a former first-round draft
choice I believe for Cleveland
we got Parker anger coming back off
injury so I believe our offensive line
is in a good spot we'll probably draft a
guard and I think you're gonna love it
chief hire me why don't they just hire
me
well Erik you're too successful doing
what you're doing you know what I'm
saying but why can't I just prove myself
in football too well you think you have
in many different ways and it's again
just only fitting Erik that you are a
NAPA please bring me back a bottle of
wine because Mike do you want my
daughter choosing dude drove me to drink
even more I did sort of meals finest man
he's he really can he's a great Ventnor
Erik he's great it'll make you cry it's
funny when we booked our hotel room up
here rich I had to tell the lady I'm
like we're not really wine drinkers
and how to reach out to you you know and
just again when my daughter looked at me
and kept saying Duke and I thought of
you and I thought you didn't you it's an
interesting matchup we got k-state I
don't want to let you go yet okay
interesting matchup between k-state and
Creighton because you know Marcus Foster
used to play at k-state and then he
transferred to Crete and so it'll be
interesting if any of that company any
of that story comes out I know it's a
national compelling story for all of the
national media what guard transferred
from k-state the Creighton was all about
things that matter
there's your eight nine it's your eight
nine out there in Charlotte and we'll
see what happens with Virginia if you
advance
but again my daughter had you advancing
but bounced by Virginia sorry to say for
you Duke
alright well we have to have enough
racket to do at the two and Arizona at
four in Kentucky at five it's it's
really loaded well all right man I don't
want to interrupt your nap a vacation
anymore I don't know I got a shower this
place has got an outdoor shower I've
never felt so uncomfortable in my life
really covered but it's like also I'm
still outside and no one no one deserves
that
all right brother take care enjoy
yourself there's Eric Stonestreet a Rich
Eisen show weekdays at noon eastern on
audience